When thinking about growth for
your app one of the most important
things is the key flows that you know
your users are going to go through.
Most people who download your app
are not going to come back later.
So you really need to get them to
the wow moment at the beginning
as soon as possible with your product.
So make them see what the value is so
that they will come back again.
One of the most important things in
A/B testing is also the creative side.
So whilst the process
itself is scientific,
and you want to use math and
data to get to the right decision,
knowing what you can do to move
the metrics that you want to do
is very much the creative part
that goes at the beginning.
And without that, then you can't do all
of the testing that comes afterwards.
If your user is waiting just
few hundred milliseconds more,
they will use your app less.
It's really important to be creative.
For instance, if your app aBARKment, you
wanted more people to be able to post
an ad, there are an infinite number
of ways that you can go about it.
For instance, you might want a permanent
entry point on at the same point in
every single screen in the app to make
sure that people always knew that they
could post an ad and they always knew
where they wanted to go to do it.
One of the most important things that
any marketer needs to think about with
their Apple product is retention.
So, it's hard to get people to try
out your app for the first time.
And if you're losing
users from your app,
that can make all of your
work that much harder.
It's like having a bucket
with holes in it.
If you're pouring water into the top,
your bucket's not going to get
full if you have that many holes.
So you concentrate on filling those
holes, increasing user retention, and
then you can get more users in.
When you're trying to measure retention,
if you're storing your own data, you
need to make sure that you store when
was the first time
that you saw this user.
So what was the date when
they first turned up?
Then you can do what's
called cohort analysis.
And this is just a way of saying for
everyone who installed on a single day,
after that, what was the likelihood that
they came back on any other given day?
Another thing that app marketers
should really care about
is the number of people who
are actively using your product.
Too many marketers focus on
just the top of the funnel and
getting the number of downloads up and
the number of new users in, but if
they're not actively using the product,
then they're not doing you any good.
So one that Facebook uses is monthly
active users and that's just the number
of people who have opened and
used your app in the last 30 days.
When you're looking at new user
acquisition, one of the most important
things is the different sources that
are providing you with new users.
So, for instance,
there's organic downloads where people
are coming direct from the App Store.
Maybe they're searching for
a specific term.
Maybe they're just browsing.
Other ones include pay channels.
Facebook, for instance,
does mobile app install ads.
If you go with paid media,
you'll usually get a lot of stats
from the actual tool itself.
So inside of Facebook,
if you pay for ads,
we'll give you really important
key of metrics, like the reach and
number of impressions that your ads
are delivering, as well as the number of
installs that you're getting that's
attributed to that campaign, and
really key metrics like the cost
that you're paying for each install.
For user engagement, there's lots of
different ways that you can look at it.
The specifics will depend
on what your app is and
which market segment you're in.
The number of times that a user
comes back inside of a month.
The daily active to monthly active
ratio is a good measure of engagement.
And also the number of things
that they do inside of the app.
If you're looking at a shopping app, for
instance, the number of items that
they view might be a good metric for
engagement, the specifics all
the way down to the app itself.
One of the most important things
that you can do for growth
is get people through the new user
experience as quickly as possible and
into the real wow
moment of your product.
So what is it that really is going to
capture the user's attention?
What is it about your product
that makes it successful?
If you have a long sign up flow, you're
going to reduce the number of people
getting through, and
that's not what you want.
Facebook puts a lot of effort into
its new user registration flow.
So when you go to sign up for
Facebook, we ask you for
as few pieces of information as we can
so that we can get you to the real point
of the product and that's seeing all
of the status updates and photos and
things that your friends
are posting in your news feed.
>> The most high level metrics for
paid social are going to be CPC,
which is cost per click.
That's the usual term that ad industry
uses for engagement on your ads.
And what that means is every
click is going to cost
you a specific amount of money.
It's also important to take into
consideration when you're thinking
about cost per click and
how much you're going to spend for
a click potentially to your product or
website, but
think about the lifetime value or
LTV of that particular customer.
So how much will they
potentially spend long term
if you're able to acquire
them with one simple ad?
Certain platforms like Twitter use
CPE which is cost per engagement.
That could be anything that a user
engages with in one of your paid ads.
That could be a favorite,
a retweet, or a direct click
through to your product or website.
Also, just for good measure,
it's good to do some basic research on
industry standards and industry
baselines for how well ads perform.
So, for example,
if you are developing a fitness app,
do some research on how fitness
industry ads perform on Twitter.
And if you're getting a return or
an engagement of, let's say, 1% on your
ads, you know that you can compare that
to whatever the industry average is.
There's no perfect way to
find industry averages or
how well relative industries perform
on specific social platforms.
I'll just say do some Googling,
do some searching, do some research.
You're going to find really helpful
free resources out there and you can at
least find some baselines to go up and
measure your performance against.
Thinking about a small brand or
a small startup,
it's really important to
embrace grassroots tactics.
Think constant engagement,
think things like giveaways and
contests, anything that can move
the needle in the right direction and
help build your social
media follower base.
It's also important to consider
things like user generated content.
Getting great content from your users,
quotes, anything tactical like that can
really pay off and
help engage with your customer base.